Las Olimpiadas Especiales también lidian con las necesidades de salud críticas.
Estudios demuestran que, en promedio,
los hombres con discapacidad intelectual
mueren 13 años antes que los hombres normales
y las mujeres con discapacidad intelectual
mueren 20 años antes que las mujeres normales.
Las Olimpiadas Especiales nos mantienen sanos
al activarnos
y hacernos participar en el deporte.
Además, nuestros entrenadores nos enseñan acerca de la nutrición y salud.
Las Olimpiadas Especiales también ofrecen exámenes de salud gratis
para los atletas que tienen dificultades para comunicarse con su médico
o con el acceso a la asistencia sanitaria.
En los Juegos Mundiales de Verano del 2015,
con mi equipo de baloncesto de Canadá jugamos con Nigeria.
El día antes de nuestro juego,
el equipo de Nigeria fue al servicio de salud para atletas de los juegos
donde a siete de sus diez miembros
se les dieron audífonos gratis
y escucharon con claridad por primera vez.
(Aplausos)
El cambio en ellos era increíble.
Estaban más emocionados, felices y confiados,
ya que su entrenador podía comunicarse verbalmente con ellos.
Y estaban muy emocionados
porque podían oír los sonidos del baloncesto,
los sonidos del silbato
y a los aficionados animando en las gradas,
sonidos que damos por sentados.
Las Olimpiadas Especiales transforman más que solo al atleta en su deporte.
Las Olimpiadas Especiales transforman vidas fuera de la cancha.
Este año, los resultados de las investigaciones mostraron
que casi la mitad de los adultos en los EE.UU.
no conocen una sola persona con una discapacidad intelectual,
y el 44% de los estadounidenses
que no tienen contacto personal con la discapacidad intelectual
los aceptan significativamente menos.
Luego está la palabra R,
que demuestra que las personas con discapacidad intelectual
siguen siendo invisibles
a demasiadas personas.
La gente lo usa como un término casual o un insulto.
Se tuiteó más de nueve millones de veces el año pasado,
y es profundamente hiriente
para mí y mis 4.5 millones de compañeros atletas de todo el mundo.
La gente no piensa que sea un insulto,
pero lo es.
Como mi compañero atleta y vocero mundial John Franklin Stephens escribió
en una carta abierta a un experto en política
que utilizó la palabra R como insulto,
"Venga algún día a los Juegos Olímpicos Especiales.
Vea si puede irse con su corazón igual".
(Aplausos)
Este año, en los Juegos Mundiales de Verano de 2015,
las personas hicieron fila durante horas
para entrar a la final de la competencia de levantamiento de pesas.
La sala estaba llena cuando mi compañero de equipo Jackie Barrett,
el alce de Terranova,
levantó 297 kg en peso muerto
y 277 kg en la posición de cuclillas,
(Aplausos)
estableciendo un nuevo récord para la Olimpiadas Especiales.
Jackie tiene el récord entre todos los levantadores de pesas en Terranova,
no solo en las Olimpiadas Especiales, sino de todos los levantadores de pesas.
Jackie era una gran estrella en Los Ángeles,
y ESPN tuitió en vivo sus levantamientos récord
y les impresionó su actuación.
Hace 50años, pocos imaginaban que gente con discapacidad intelectual
pudiera hacer nada por el estilo.
Este año, 60 000 espectadores llenaron el famoso LA Memorial Coliseum
para ver la ceremonia de inauguración de los Juegos Mundiales
y animar a los atletas de 165 países
alrededor del mundo.
Lejos de escondernos,
estábamos aplaudiendo y celebrando.
Las Olimpiadas Especiales enseñan a los atletas
a estar seguros y orgullosos de sí mismos.
Las Olimpiadas Especiales enseñan al mundo
que las personas con discapacidad intelectual
merecen respeto e inclusión.
(Aplausos)
Ahora tengo sueños y logros en mi deporte,
buenos entrenadores,
respeto y dignidad,
mejor salud,
y estudio para llegar a ser entrenador personal.
(Aplausos)
Ya no estoy escondido, acosado
y estoy aquí dando una charla TED.
(Aplausos y vítores)
El mundo es un lugar diferente gracias a las Olimpiadas Especiales,
pero todavía hay que ir más lejos.
Así que la próxima vez que vean a alguien con discapacidad intelectual,
espero vean su capacidad.
La próxima vez que alguien utilice la palabra R,
espero le digan lo mucho que duele.
Espero se involucren en las Olimpiadas Especiales.
(Aplausos)
Me gustaría terminar con un pensamiento.
Nelson Mandela dijo:
"El deporte tiene el poder de cambiar el mundo".
Las Olimpiadas Especiales está cambiando el mundo
mediante la transformación de 4.5 millones de atletas
y brindándonos un lugar para tener confianza,
reunirnos con los amigos,
no ser juzgados
y llegar a sentirse y a ser campeones.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)